[Hawaiian-style music]
- All right!
Man, today's gonna
be stresful, guys.
I'm gonna admit it.
The Comedy Central execs
are coming
and they're judging us,
okay?
So I'm here to relieve
a little stress with weed
and this game
that I made up.
It's called speed golf.
And the rules
are pretty simple.
You hit the ball,
you sprint after it,
and then the next guy
comes up,
he counts to five,
then he hits the ball,
then he sprints after it,
then the next guy
comes up,
he counts to five,
then he hits the ball,
then he sprints after it,
and it--it keeps going.
You guys get that.
The goal is to get done playing
golf as fast as possible,
because golf sucks.
- Are you going to keep
talking and smoking,
or are you actually
gonna play?
- All right, having a--
having a high moment there.
Okay, good.
Thank you, Vlad.
Keep me on my toes, baby.
- You're killing me.
- Pfft pfft pfft pfft pfft.
Now remember, the goal is
to go as fast as possible.
[club hits ball]
[intense percussive music]
- All right,
you're up, Jak.
- This is going to
be great.
- One, two,
three, four, five.
[club hits]
- Oh, my God,
it's going to hit Adam.
What do you yell?
I'm from the Bronx.
I don't know what to say.
- Uh, fore.
- Fore! Fore! Fore, fore!
- Not four, five.
Ow!
- Ooh, shit.
- Come on.
- That was--
that was awesome.
[theme music plays]